hello
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
find out
differentiates these protests of the
last several days
is the scale and widespread nature of
them
there have been episodes of unrest and
uh public anger at at government policy
in China even during the Xi Jinping era
but those protests were relatively small
relatively localized and it's that a
national character widespread nature
that I think makes it a much more
potentially volatile
and potentially more
threatening
set of problems that the that the uh
that the party in China has to deal with
it
is
when it comes to protests protests that
we're seeing in China protests that
we've seen for
different reasons uh in Iran in other
places
our position is uh is the same
everywhere which is that we support the
right of people everywhere
to peacefully protest to make known
their views their concerns and their
frustrations
leads this kind of protest because China
has no political environment and for
past 70 years the cleaned out any
people
intellectual or or media who can risk
any question so there's no
no ecosystem in the political situation
I'm quite cynical about it because
everything
too many and too many young people has
been arrested and and other people
become a silent and also I've seen the
European nations are never really
support human rights in different
Nations under they have their own agenda
they want to do business with China
that's most that's a priority and so
today is extremely difficult for anybody
want to have a change
foreign